l'autorisation de port d'armes c'est
parce que monsieur benalla était menacée
il avait été gendarme
il est formé au maniement des armes il
lui semblait logique de porter une arme
pour assurer sa propre sécurité
il n'avait aucune sécurité par ailleurs
donc pas de chauffeur pas de protection
il est au plus proche du président de la
république
il est donc soumis évidemment à des
menaces importantes en matière
terroriste
il était menacé et il n'avait pas
d'armes donc il a sollicité une
autorisation de port d'armes qui lui a
été délivré et qui ont été délivrés sous
une formulation que évidemment monsieur
benalla ne maîtrisait pas le préfet de
police et a marqué missions de police
c'est certainement une erreur de
formulation
parce que ce n'était pas sa mission mais
peu importe l'important c'est que ils
puissent porter son arme et protéger sa
famille c'est tout si on s'arc boutent
là dessus et qu'on dit benalla avec un
port d'armes c'est forcément qu'il
assurait la sécurité du président je
rappellerai que dans un bloc 43 ya six
cartouches et c'est pas avec six
cartouches que vous allez assurer la
sécurité d'un président de la république
c'est c'est un peu délirant de le
prétendre
donc monsieur benalla il n'était pas là
pour assurer la protection du président
d'autres qui sont des vrais spécialistes
étaient là pour le faire il n'en a
jamais eu ni la prétention ni les moyens